all right jimmy
jimmy oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um well
i was born in compton but i i was raised
here in south central
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents
yeah well i mean yeah like in the
beginning
i guess you could say because my mom
when i was like
three she took me and my other little
sister to mexico and
and left us there for a while so i was
like probably like six
i got to like meet my mom i guess
and but she went to pick us back like
pick us up and bring us back to
the us i guess she couldn't take care of
us at the moment so
you know she had she did what she had to
do
yeah and my my like she wasn't like
i've never got to meet my real dad like
but
that i have like my stepdad i guess you
call him like that's that's pops you
know
like i love him he's a good man you know
um the other guy i don't know who the
[ __ ] it is truly told
i don't really care but um you're real
dead
yeah yeah i don't know that um
but my parents were cool you know it's
just
i don't know i guess i'm the black sheep
of the family
but your mom was in your life most most
of your life yeah my mom is super cool
she's like she's like she's like my best
friend you know
like she's like my crime like my
criminal i guess you could say
in a way she's done some crazy things
for me
that i'd be like well not just any
mother would do you know
like stuff they could get in trouble you
know and
and that he's always been there is just
that he started [ __ ] out like
well i'm the one who got him into that
[ __ ] you know he just started messing up
and now
they both live in mexico because they
got deported because
because of me basically how are they
what
what troubles they get into well
see my uh like i started
like i started gangbanging right and
i guess you could say luckily i i
i ended up moving to a house where it
was like next to a dose puzzle
you know what it was next to a dope spot
like the other oh i said yeah
so i figured like hey i
i couldn't do that and i just went and
hung around with them
and they said you know i'm selling i'm
selling dope i'm selling crack
and it just started moving up because
the spot got raided
they ended up [ __ ] taking most of the
people in
and by some coincidence me and one
homeboy
were left like untouched
because we weren't there at the moment
and
all the stash got left to us you know
so it's like we just started blowing up
from that point on
and my dad i made my house into a dull
spot
and i got my dad into drugs you know
like
he was he used to do a little a little
bit of cold when he would drink like any
other
mexican and [ __ ] but um
when i had a bunch of it and he would
ask me for like a little bit i'll be
like here just take this bunch don't be
asking me for more you know
and one thing led to another he he
started setting dope for me and
he ended up going to prison for like i
think it was like two years
two three years and he got out about two
years ago
but i try to uh i try to cross him back
and they caught him
that same week that he got out so he
ended up going back for another two
years
so he he don't want to come back you
don't want to try it again you know
and and well mom she was going to get
her
her papers done already too but
it's like when it was time for me to
show up in court by that time i was
already smoking like the open [ __ ] like
that so
i would just tell the judge like [ __ ]
off or you know like i don't care about
this like
to his face just go to sleep right there
when they're trying to ask me questions
and they denied her their papers and
because of that she had to take off to
mexico you know
yeah how would you describe your
childhood
man look from
look i've always been a a geek a nerd
like
you know i i like educating myself
i was an honor student all the way to
like eighth grade when i graduated
still as an honor student um
i went into high school and i
i like i started liking girls and
you know it's like girls they want like
kids with money or
you know kids that are popular and me
being a schoolboy wasn't having that
you know so i figured hey i
remember i took a little i bought a sack
of weight and i rolled up a blood and i
pulled up
and now everybody want to be cool so i'm
like all right
this is what to do i started smoking
weed
and started hanging around with the
brown crowd and ha
here i am you know
um it went like from like i
i went from like a perfect the perfect
child
like not perfect i'm talking about like
in school and stuff like that i was a
good kid
but when i hit high school wow
everything is like
i ended up going to juvenile hall for
the first time then from that point on
it was like
in and out of jail all the way till
recently you know and getting your
parents in trouble too
yeah like but with them it was something
else it was like
i started getting carried away because
of the money
you know there was so much money coming
in it's like
you know my mom's mad i could i hear
mama take this or hear mama
look what i bought for you and uh the
blue with the brew
with a nice bracelet you know she's
happy again and
i get so dope again you know but i
wasn't thinking about all that [ __ ] i
was just thinking more like
let me get my money you know let me [ __ ]
these [ __ ] and
you know and that's it but
that [ __ ] turned around and bit me in
the ass cause
a lot of [ __ ] happened because of that
you know you ever get caught
yeah i got that's the first time i went
to prison after
after they got after the spa guy raided
and it became my spot it was more like
like how long can i last out here you
know because we already had undercovers
looking for the rest of us
but we didn't care because we were we
were smoked the [ __ ] out you know we
were doped up
and truly told i really didn't care
because i got the house shot up i got
the house running into
the house got raided man all bad
you know and um but when my when my
house got raided it's like i was the
only one who got caught
me and some dude that was just passing
by but they got him on accident
but i remember i saw my mom and my dad
pulling up
and my dad in the truck and they just
put it in reverse and just
took off acting like they didn't see
nothing but i already knew
what was going to happen if if it ever
came down to it
but i was careless you know like when
you [ __ ] drugged up you you don't
give a [ __ ]
what about drugs were you selling man
i'm telling you oh it's because i got
too carried away
we start i would we we had coke cocaine
was the main thing but out of cocaine
you're making crack
we're making cocaine right then we
started
selling math which we already had math
any [ __ ] way
but you know a lot of us smoking so it's
like it's hard to smoking and selling at
the same time unless you're selling
quantities
and that's what i i figured like we
should do it like this
and it's like i didn't want to stop
there i wanted
to get bigger you know so i started
buying stolen rims for example
i started sending crackers out right
here downtown to do little missions to
get jewelry for me pay them with crack
you know
[ __ ] um i had some i had
some girls yeah i ain't gonna say they
get out they're hauling it because
they're they're not
it's more like here i'm gonna take you
to this club get this [ __ ] drunk
pull him up and we're going to come up
okay and you know and just come out for
whatever you got you drop them
like i'm not going to say rob them you
know like
the girl would turn a trick like we now
like kind of yeah like but we would only
just trick them into like
going somewhere where they're by
themselves you know and from that point
on
it's cause look i'm gonna be honest my
hunger used to like drug them up with
some [ __ ] called g you know i don't know
if you've heard of that [ __ ] but
it's liquid it's like like
um i don't know what it used to be to be
honest with you all i know is that
you drink i'm gonna say a
a cat full like this like a two liter
soda cafe
a full one you're passing out drunk
gone you know it's supposed to be
something to
help your muscles heal after a workout
you know but people started [ __ ]
around with it you know in a different
way
it's cool though like if you drink it
like like
at a pace like it's cool where's the
[ __ ]
this is [ __ ] but if you drink too much
of it i swear to god you'll pass the
[ __ ] out and
it's happened to me before you know to
where you wake up and you're like what
the [ __ ]
where's my money at with my stuff like
and you were with a hood right you don't
even [ __ ] know yesterday and you know
and she came up now it's her [ __ ]
you know so how much prison time have
you done like i i've done two terms
one was 24 months with half
but i ended up doing uh like 18 months
off of that because i went to the show
i did a shoot shoot term and then the
second what is the shoe term
it's like it's like gel inside jail huh
you know
like why is it called shoe program the
shoe program is it's like
long term it's not like it's not like
like you in the county you go to the
hall you go to the hall and they put you
inside a cell where you don't see tv or
talk to other people for a while like
i don't know i've been to a hole as well
so i like i was there for like 30 days
30 40 days no the shoe is more like when
you're doing
time in the shoe like literally like in
locked away from everybody no no you'll
never get to touch somebody else or talk
to somebody else directly you know
and um i did the shoe term
i i got to prison that same day
the next day um they put me in a cell
with this
one dude who wouldn't want to show his
paperwork to nobody right
and i'm like what the [ __ ] it's my first
time in prison but even i know that
you're supposed to show your paperwork
you know that's how people know who the
[ __ ] you are and what you're
in there for so he didn't want to i
talked to a people right there and
they're like you know what this was a jk
he's stupid he's like cuckoo
don't listen but i was just curious you
know because
he had there was another another
cellular hiss who was there and
this will [ __ ] them up and
he said he was in there for rape so now
you got somebody in there for rape
but you don't want to ask him for the
paperwork
makes no sense so i just kind of started
talking with this guy you know
like trying to get cool with him luckily
he
he knew my humble coco so coco he like i
know homie coco
we started talking right and i just
started like kind of asking him low key
like
so what you in here for so how long you
know making a conversation then he told
me
oh yeah i i raped this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he's like i raped the [ __ ] [ __ ]
because
he was shaking his ass everywhere he he
wanted to give it to me but he didn't at
the end
but i still took that caller cops he was
doing 12 years
also from wtk maywood that full he's a
[ __ ] anyway
yeah so i i i went and told the main
dude like hey dude you know this was in
here for right he just told me how the
[ __ ] you gonna have him here even i know
you're supposed to clean that [ __ ] up
he's like don't worry we're gonna take
care of it long story short
he sends me a kite saying hey full you
know you gotta take care of this guy
because he's your sally as your
responsibility
and um you're gonna do it with somebody
else
and yeah i was like what the [ __ ]
i thought i was just gonna take flight
on this guy but now they're like now you
gotta clean the yard
and i [ __ ] it it is what it is i ain't
got no choice
and we did that same day in in
in in ciao and lunch and dinner actually
in the yard um they
they had me meet up with another guy
chucky from watts
that phone he was good he's solid homie
um he told me you know what i'm a guy
too don't trip
he just hands me a blade you know like
what the [ __ ]
i was nervous as [ __ ] for real like
nervous
so we started walking and in the middle
of the yard
like because we had to cross the yard to
get to the [ __ ]
to the lunch area i just see chucky step
to the side
and this guy kept walking just looking
and he looks to that side and
boom he gets him in the neck boom
when he started falling back when he
fell back boom boom
twice and then i don't know what the
[ __ ] happened somebody snatched that
[ __ ] away from me and a bunch of dudes
started [ __ ] that fool up and it's
like
is the cleanup crew was there you know
that [ __ ] was crazy
like everything's like on point
i didn't even know i had the blade i
didn't even know where the [ __ ] the
blade went
i don't know i was getting amazed with
the super soaker and getting punched
with
beanbags and [ __ ] like that but yeah
i ended up going to a shoe and from i
was supposed to do like 12 13 months
i ended up doing 16 months like 15 16
months
and rolled out the shoe that's what you
get for murder
i don't know i was in there for murder
oh no no
that's crazy now that you talk about it
so the homie chuckie like hey fu don't
say [ __ ] all right
he starts putting me up on game so i'm
like all right uh when we went to court
because they picked up the case right we
went to court
i swear on everything i love that this
[ __ ] pulled they bring him
and this was right there like he pulls
up and they're like
oh can you point at the people who did
this and he like looks
looks at me and looks at me like nah it
wasn't them
and they're like what you mean it was in
there like i don't know who the [ __ ] it
was it was a lot of people beating me up
but he was stabbed though he was stabbed
up right here right here he had
his [ __ ] hand on [ __ ] with the
bandages like
i was scared as [ __ ] though because they
were like they were talking about
attempted murder or murder
but nah and he didn't even snitch but he
still pissed it up so he's still a pc
you know but he didn't [ __ ] snitch
and i mean
whether he raped that [ __ ] or not i
mean i got a kill to him you know
because anybody else would have been
like hell yeah it was them get him
so you interesting story did you for
real
yeah so you joined the gang of what age
well like at 14 14 15
yeah and that's what kind of opened the
door for the drugs
yeah well kind of
yeah that was it basically it was a the
females are like i like man i like
females you know
like that's my thing so so you're down
in south central figaro street runs
right through the heart of it
lots of girls down there hell yeah that
are doing business
you'll pick up some of the girls well
no i i have i don't like i have
because let's be realistic there'll be
some bad ass [ __ ] you know like for
real for real
and i don't care what guy [ __ ] says
they don't they don't do that [ __ ]
believe me if they had the money they
come across it
the opportunity just happened to happen
right then and then it'll go through
but um hell yeah but see
females and figaro be having a [ __ ] the
past attitude and
they all they look even though my brain
tells me
they just don't they just want to come
up dude they just gonna come up on your
money it'd be like my dick telling me
something i was like man let's just go
get it let's just get it one time
well see i'll be [ __ ] love cause i'll
be smoking math right so
a [ __ ] be trying to [ __ ] for
like a long time and
these females are having that [ __ ] you
know so it'd be
like hard to be like hey you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] now we're like what's up let's kick
it the whole night
it'd be rare when they be like yeah you
know but most of the time they'd be like
nah like right now there's this much
i'll be like [ __ ]
again i've done it but it sucks you know
because
let's be like i'm a man you know and i
guess what pushes me is
knowing i'm [ __ ] a new person you
know every so often
so when they pull up and they're
i'm about to [ __ ] this female but it's
different than
than me hanging out with her and
chilling drinking and smoking doing
whatever [ __ ] drugs we want
to picking up a girl and you know i'm
fake and be like come on and she's just
going to hop in and
spread her legs open and go for it like
like [ __ ] i ain't even ready yeah what
the [ __ ]
you gave me but um yeah i i don't know
look
truth be told i don't know why the hell
i do it
but i do and you know what
look i [ __ ] you not most of the time
i don't even get my nut
why because i'll be smoking [ __ ] you're
not be smoking math
so what does meth do to you in terms of
your sexual
behavior like right now i'm already used
to that [ __ ] you know
i'm hyper active as it is but
like in the beginning that [ __ ] will
[ __ ] i don't know it turns you like
i'm
like a maniac like a maniac like i don't
know
if it's the same thing for girls but us
guys at least me
i i'll get a rouse quick you know and
but like not aroused more like a [ __ ]
horn dog like
like horny like you know on some way out
[ __ ] like um
forget a viagra pay or ecstasy pill nah
that should have you thinking like way
out [ __ ] [ __ ] don't even go in your head
like you already mind [ __ ] this girl so
so so much so many different ways
then when it's time for the real thing
it's like what the [ __ ]
it's not what it seems you know it's
crazy to
to explain it but so you've been using
meth for how long
since i was like 14 15.
so you're you're you you're a regular
you're an addict
yeah i guess i'm an addict yeah yeah
it's a really popular drug now it is
it is but but
it's not what it used to be like [ __ ]
right now is [ __ ] cut
it's it's like it's rare to find some
good [ __ ] you know because they all
these other chemicals they
they're adding to it see back then they
were like
when speed burn came out for example and
then it was
it was uh glass
then you know it became crystal and all
these [ __ ] names for it
but in the beginning it used to be the
[ __ ] like
for real that should get you hyped up
not giving a [ __ ] about
nothing about nothing but getting your
nut or at least that was me
like that [ __ ] would turn me crazy like
oh man i gotta go find me a [ __ ] so i
could [ __ ]
you know whether it was like on the
website um websites or
or you know but when i'm out when i
i won't lie it's been times where i just
start walking
and i'm walking but through the whole
stroll you know through where the
[ __ ] be at
i'm just looking like which one
you know don't get me wrong a lot of
them be throwing it at me
but it'd be like i'm picky because
they don't be about how good they look
for me it'd be like
basically you do this drug to use this
drug
because if you do that we're in the same
boat so you want somebody to do the drug
with you and hell yeah
yeah whole party exactly like party and
play yeah
you know but it's rare to find those and
when you do
it'd be like man you can't trust this
[ __ ] for [ __ ]
cause you know she a drug addict one
you you you fall asleep that's it your
[ __ ] is gone
you know especially if it's [ __ ]
little crackers
but um yeah
so do you have children i got two boys i
had a baby girl she passed away when she
was three months
her name looked tripp her real name was
baby
felony perez that was her birth name
yeah she passed when she was three
months um
then i i ended up doing some [ __ ] that
made me
you know fleeing the country
to mexico i was over there working like
an illegal because i didn't have mexico
papers
for five years but um
i had another baby i had another two
boys with the same baby mama
and um and even though i'd be like like
[ __ ] these hoes and spending money
here and there
or or on drugs or [ __ ] like that like i
consider myself a good dad you know i'm
always there for my kids
like i just got here last night around 4
a.m from dileno you know they live all
the way the [ __ ] out there i'm in south
central
that's two hours away i got a car i just
got a job like
two three months ago you know and um
yeah but i love them and they love me
like crazy
because my dad was cool to me so because
of him i'm cool with my kids
you know that's great are you working
yeah i mean no no no unemployment takes
care of me right now
atd you know with the pandemic is like
[ __ ] they're paying me basically what i
was winning
you know so i'm not working but
i do work though i do work i do work as
a
contractor um
and sales my thing it sells you know
like anything that has to do with sales
and the crystal meth doesn't get in the
way of your your work
yeah it does i ain't gonna lie it does
in the sense that
in the night time i'm up and i'm trying
to
fall asleep until three four in the
morning when
when i was working it's like i gotta get
up at seven
6 30 because i work in culver city from
malay to over there with the traffic it
gets packed you know
so um
then i see like i smoked the [ __ ] out
right now so i completely forgot what
the [ __ ] i was talking about that's
crazy
so you must have some crazy stories
about the girls on figaro
and doing crystal meth you've been
robbed before
have i been robbed before by a few hell
yeah look oh
[ __ ] now rob though it wasn't i i ain't
gonna say rob
like give me your [ __ ] that yeah that
just
stuff disappears oh yeah like like that
like i told you
that g that ga no joe look don't get me
wrong you [ __ ] on that g
and then you do it the right amount and
[ __ ] dude it's like
you're gonna you're gonna have the time
of your life i don't care what
the female says she don't do she gonna
do it willingly
like for real like willingly just don't
care too much she's gonna pass the [ __ ]
out she ain't gonna do [ __ ]
you know and when i say pass out i don't
mean just like
like just slowly go to sleep now i'm
talking about
you're up and the next thing you know
boom floor
[ __ ] up sleep knocked out until the
next day
blacked out completely look oh man it's
crazy
well let me tell you about that one time
so i i i
my hunger told me hey fool come through
you know i got this [ __ ] wants me to
blah blah
when i get there turns out that i went
to high school with her right
so i'm like so we kicked it out i was so
she like
hey well let's go kick it i'm like well
look they let you babysitting this kid
what the [ __ ] you gonna do you're gonna
kick it you're gonna stay right here
she's like
[ __ ] that i'm gonna leave him right here
she gave him five bucks we gone i took
that [ __ ] to momo you know
and the moment we're right there [ __ ]
smoking dope and
you know we're right there talking and
you could tell this [ __ ] once a day
because
she's telling me she like like you know
i could take dick like
the [ __ ] you don't say that [ __ ] out the
blue you know that
you're crazy as [ __ ] but all right
anyway
i told her hey i got this g and she's
like well [ __ ] this [ __ ] around
i took some she took some but i hadn't
gone to sleep for like i don't know i'm
gonna say two three days so you could
only imagine
taking some of that it's meant to knock
you out anyway
i was already like this you know i
i shut my eyes and when i opened him she
was gone
and i had dope i had money my cell
phones like man i had
my money like oh man anyway
everything was there except the cash
except the cash
she took off with that [ __ ] she took off
with like 650 bucks
which ain't really much but sure that
[ __ ] helps you know
that that's that's a moment for like two
nights
two hurrahs you know but um yeah
um she thought i wasn't gonna find her
but
you know social media facebook that she
helps out a lot
so i just punched her number her [ __ ]
papa like oh man
i started seeing when she was live and
when she wasn't when she was live i'm
like i was ready around her area like
i'm gonna catch you she went live oh i
know where she at whoa pulled up like
paige put my money at
she like oh [ __ ] but um
i was cool with her boyfriend even well
i guess i wasn't that cool because i was
[ __ ] her while danica was in jail so
but um yeah she ain't so like i'mma pay
you i promise you i'm i promise you
i i ended up just you know she paid me
probably like 100 bucks out of that
the restaurant she was just she was
tracked the [ __ ] out too you know she
was on a good one
so what do you see for the future of
your life you're
you're using meth not likely to stop
where do you see your life going from
here
look it's crazy you asked me that [ __ ]
because right now i'm in a predicament
where it's like
i'm up in the air like when i told you i
came from delano
look this time i got out i was supposed
to fix [ __ ] with baby mama
but i didn't i got out and i went
straight into [ __ ] around with matt
and i [ __ ] that up so now it's like
i come to la because i i live in l.a
where right now i really don't have a
place to be honest with you
i just been renting hotels after hotels
and the money i do get and i've been
coming up
you know like i like to hustle i like to
make my money but
when i get it look i [ __ ] tonight i
don't know what the [ __ ] could be about
these hoes that
and then i'm not satisfied it's like
okay i got me a hoe i got a room
we got drugs we got all this [ __ ] we
gonna [ __ ] we got porn going all this
[ __ ] right
and then it's like i'm [ __ ] her and i
haven't even bust my nut
when i'm like stopping making an excuse
throwing on my clothes slowly walking
her to the store and then walking away
from her
looking for the next one you know like
and
i guess it'd just be me i won or i don't
know what the [ __ ] but now i got the
next one
and and while i'm in the room i got
another one texting me already or i'm
over here
finding another one over here it's like
and then the [ __ ] about it is like i
don't [ __ ] five six holes this [ __ ]
today the money gone
the drugs are gone and i still haven't
busted my nut like what the [ __ ]
you know that's that kind of [ __ ] and
i'm not like look
i ain't nothing wrong with masturbating
and [ __ ]
but me personally i don't do it i like
to get my nut you hear me
and when you get it like that naturally
like with a female or you know
doing what the [ __ ] you like to do is
like it's a
it's a better feeling you know like come
on but don't get me wrong i jacked up
before like who has
it you know but it's not my thing so
that's why i get [ __ ] up because
i got a big appetite you know different
females do different things and
and as a [ __ ] you know my life is [ __ ]
up like for real like
look don't get me wrong i
it was a point in my life where i said i
was in prison actually
i was in the show i was waiting for a
letter everybody kept getting letters
everybody like
[ __ ] everybody get in the little letter
what about me i didn't get
[ __ ] so i was mad so the next day
i was yelling out the door like my my
girl didn't write to me can i get a [ __ ]
that [ __ ] and you hear the homie like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you know from themselves
so this the librarian comes and she's
like look
look stop stressing here read this and
you know it might help you and she walks
away she gives me a paper where the
saint said
worthy is a man who expects nothing for
he shall never be disappointed
you know so ever since then i figured
like you know what for real i shouldn't
expect [ __ ] from nobody that way i'm
never disappointed
anything that does come up is like it's
profit basically
so yeah i started doing that and i
started telling myself like any [ __ ]
mission i could do to make money
whether it's dirty money good money
clean money however you want to call it
it's green at the end of the day you
know
and i'm like i'm gonna do it i'm gonna
go for it whether i do it right whether
i do it wrong whether
it comes out good positive negative [ __ ]
believe me i've done some [ __ ]
missions that just [ __ ] me
up like right here [ __ ] in mexico
[ __ ] with cartels like some way out
deep [ __ ] and
then i done some stupid [ __ ] that just
got me paid you know like
like i like i don't know like
um i found like i find this car
it got the [ __ ] trunk open [ __ ] it's
the trunk of it i'm just curious i open
it
boom what happens i find 20 bands 20 g's
right there like what the [ __ ] like
i'm gone i was gone missing m.i.a
straight to tj i was living the life for
like about a week
a lot of gambling but mostly monthly
[ __ ]
you know like for real although it's
cheaper too
you picked up diseases doing this stuff
huh [ __ ] look [ __ ] why you gotta ask me
something like that putting me on black
look
[ __ ] this time but look i'm clean
though look this time i went too [ __ ]
uh this last time actually um
i'm in there and they're like they're
testing me right because
i got psoriasis i guess i stress too
much you know like
they're taking a test and they're like
hey
you know you know you got um
you know how they put you a shot and
it's supposed to be like a little bubble
tv some [ __ ] like that yeah i'm like
they're like you you tested positive for
that you're like what the [ __ ]
for real for what for that tb thing i
don't know what the [ __ ]
tuberculosis uh-huh is it it's
supposed to be like a little bubble i
don't know but um
they said that it was because i was
[ __ ] the wrong wrong females or some
[ __ ] like that you know
and anyway they gave me a pill for what
like
oh no actually it was a shot it was a
shot
once a week for three weeks
and that [ __ ] hurt that [ __ ] hurt i
never took shots like that in my life
i think it was it was a penicillin
and something else that [ __ ] hurts so
painful like oh
and it hurts for like the whole [ __ ]
week you know you know her for just
it hurts when that she's going in and
then you're numb
for like the next three four days you
can't even sleep on that side
uh never again
condoms all the way for real
all right jimmy thank you so much for
sharing your story man appreciate it
you